どうもみなさんこんにちは
初めてホワイトポーズを使いますといったんだけど使わないから
でせっかく
せっかく方がカッコイーカッコいいよねペックスある方が
よろしくね
どうもすいません
今だね兼松さんの話いいお話でしたね
さっきねそこで隣になったんですよ
なんか
ショートパンツ履いたかっこいいお兄さんが出てきてあの日先さのあなたは私の後です
からっておっおったそういったんじゃなくて
まああの
二人で話しますからって押しちゃったので君が杖って聞いたんですよ
下谷僕はもう13年前受けてますから
そう変わっただけだとすごいわかりだと思って
なんか若い人ばっかりその後スピーカーになりそうだから
さっき学生の人に
少し私は年取ってるけど修理は他にないんですかって言ったら
いや40歳くらいの方も腕になりますからって言ってそうか40でもこだわった旬なの
かと
スープ
まあ年寄り臭い話なんですが
今グローバリゼーションということについて私は何か学生代打で3つ誤解があると思う
んでその話をしてそれから
少し大人の人の責任ということについても時間があればなそうかなと思っています
3つの誤解というのは一つは英語につい
もう一つは
国境
国ということについ3番目は
日本を知るべきかどうか言う
この3つです英語については大学受験を経てい
まあこういうちゃんとした学校に入ってくると
まあ英語はまぁ一応出来るから他のことを学をしっかり勉強しようとかあるいは
英文だけじゃダメなんだ中身が大事なんだ
英文はいいかの中身をしっかりという話を時々聞きます
まあよくえい航された方の中にもそういう話をする
特に英語があんまり不得意な方がそういうことを言われるような気がするんですけれど
も
私はそれは両方とも全く間違いだと思います
大学に入ったからこそをしっかり英語を勉強しなきゃいけ
第二外国はもちろん大事なんです私の第二外国語はフランス語で
ずいぶん一生懸命勉強してきました
だけど私のいた外務省でもアラビア語の専門家もロシア語の専門家を中国の戦法かも
フランス語の専門家もみんな英語は
帰ってきます
何故かといえば
僕も情報国際の情報は
くるし
鵬翔は英語で行いし契約は英語で行われる
か英語はできた上で
大学ができれば
世界が広がる私の友達はずいぶん今日の
理由はしたか
フラン進学 by して食事をしたりするんですけどもすぐするで広がります
だけど英語ができないけど
もう一つ英語かー
じゃなくて中身だと
いう話これもね僕はすごくおかしいと思う
それはね60歳ぐらいの人はもうそれでいいかもしれない
だけど20代30代の人は両方できるはずです
もちろん英語だけじゃなく中身も英語もできる
なんか変な例えですけどね
ラーメンが好きだ
いう人が
ラーメンてお汁とそれから
綿でできていますよねどっちが大事なんだと
面が大事なんだ落ちがとうとうみってことはないので両方やっぱり
なきゃいけないいうことみたいなもんだと思えば
あまり分かりやすく無いからな
うんっ
英語ができるとはどういうことかと言うと
ということで言えば
引くのは一番大事なんですが
はへテレビでも映画でも観て7割くらいはわかる
話しするのは人様の間に割って入るぐらいできる
そして読むのは新聞だったら30分で4本だったらに30で読める
それペグレベルでやっとできる
使えるレベルだったんだろうと思います
新聞を3日間かけて呼べる家に次の下僕ちゃうよねそれ
そもそも
なぜ聞くのが一番大事かっては私が一番若い時ですね
何を言われたかッ
空間で一番国際会議で出て誰かが日本のことを侮辱したり
そこでやることしかない
手を挙げて反論するか席を立って退場するかどっちかかな
これは
愚直されたかどうかを壊すわかんなきゃダメですよね
分からなかったらで黙ってみんなと一緒に手をたたいたりちゃう
大敗大変なことになりますよね
はかるって事は本当に大事なんですそれが
英語についての話ですん
次はねえ
今日ってことなんですけれども今いろんなことで棒がデスクにもう情報もお金もみんな
ボーダーレスになっているということで国というのがなくなっているような感じがする
かもしれん
しかしドっぽい全然そうじゃないんですね
フリットはますますというよ
国が大事だからこそ
国境が抱いたからこそ泉岳問題まで久御山でウクライナマリアっつーの問題もあるわけ
ですよね
例えば後藤さんと床を
乙降ったんだけれど
窮地に陥った時にスラム
その関係で
誰が助ける施工も使う
ヨルダンと誰かす褒章するのか一緒なこと誰が話をするのか
日本国なんですよね
国連でもなんでもない
日本が責任を持つ尿守るの場日本人を守るの分
日本なんですん
ですから国境ってのはそういう意味では全くなくなってないもう一つは
国際機関これは何となく腑により上にあるような期間みたいな気がするけど全然そんな
ことはない
各国がお金を出し合って作っている
格好がどうやってそれを通じて自分の国益を増進しようかと思っているものがあっ
思って私はいいんじゃないか
だから私は国際機関の代表でしたけど
wto whoi と国連を通じてどう言ってにほっ
国
国益を増進させてそれで石火での平和変えにもつながるのかということ
日本を置いて考えてるわけではない
例えば国際機関の長とか漢文
みんなが選挙で日いろんな人だそう
各国が競争で出そうとするんですよ
でそれは何故かといえば
僕が代議士を出している各地方が代議車
例えばあっパンは山口館でする代議士で一旦総理大臣だったら日本全体のことを考え
なきゃいけないけれども
やはり山口県が出してるんですよ山口県がを落としちゃったらも出てこられない
それと同じように
緒方先生もこのタイプの先生だったんですけど w あの家で unhcr だした時
の日本が4国が応援して出した
そういう
関係があることを忘れてなんとファットしたもんだと考えると全く間違うと思います
それ私はずっと国債券を担保してきた経験から
3番目の子回程度は日本にを知る
fox 外国に出る前に国際社会に出れば日本知らなきゃいけないというふうに思い
ます
それ違うと思います
順番が違う外国に行けば日本のことを知らなきゃいけないということに気づ
もしそれをやる前に日本のことを指導私は日本も一番強みは日本の文化だと思います
だけどお茶
花の
カブキー富士山和食いろんなことを勉強しているとに通し撮っちゃいますよ
まずでてっていっ
それから外国の人の関心もお茶の花じゃなくてもしかしたら隈研吾の建築家あるいは
い制度4日
村上春樹の小説家
映画かいろんなものがありえましたから
何も日本のこと全部白なくしている必要全くない
アメリカ人縦にアメリカがここ全部車内凛々しいんだってしてませんよとにかく早く出
て行
私はずっと大事だと思います
知らなくて恥ずかしいということ
よく言う人がいますけどそれ
私が違う
というふうに思います
だから結論いうパス英語をしっかり勉強してほしい
それから二番目は
国境っていうのはしっかりあるということを覚えていただきたい
3番目は
日本を知るというようなことそれは究極的には大事だ
しかしそれにとらわれないで出て行くそしてできればみんなについ
する話
今ハリウッド映画のメイン c オリンピックでもいいしみんながを
広がっているものを話せるようにするみればしたケンカ佐賀県から来た人が
この中にいて毎日会うたびに俺の犬の話しようじゃないかって言ったらみんな何かくや
になっちゃうでしょ
まあいると申し訳ないけれどもしかし
だから一般的な話をできることをすることでは国際人へのパスポートであろうという
ふうに私は思います
2時は大人の責任って最後に2本残ったんでお話をいたします
何か
時々入ってきて帰って季節何年かが外国に行って帰ってくると今の
この人が
人は覇気がないと
いた大黒休学しない
よくいって愚痴をこぼします
おいおいた違うんじゃないかとはでしょ
今の日本の
中学高校の教育受けてアメリカの大学に行って
冶具ばわかるかとはするわけじゃないじゃああの
お金はどうやって工面するんだたの高い
へ
入学金と授業料
じゃあ方から帰って来て出発のと旧
大丈夫だろうかジャック一緒に入ってから
中華つの時にちょっと大学みたいに帰国し両顎を作っているのかといったら大抵のキー
を作ってない
だんだんよくなってきましたけどねそれから会社に入ってからもなんとなく通訳良い
みたいにならないかどうかそこら辺の事全部つ
大人の方がきちんとしなきゃいけない
入学しろよというのは言ってみれば
おしろよとパ
220よっ
んですけれども遠泳をする前に
平泳ぎの今日は教えて
それから帰ってきたらちゃんと映画終わったら
にも外でも用意しておくとそういうシステムができている
一番初めにやらなきゃいけないなにかけろ中学高校の英語のレベルアップする
それは何かといえば中学高校の英語の先生を
広告費で
全員外国に送り出すことです1年間
1年間を送り出す費は100億円ですいっ
仙人毎年先生になりますけどさん先生になって3年目ぐらい全員出す
もう少し違う
なら数1年間行ってくるだけで自信を持って子どもたちに制する
1人の先生が
32の+5+教えて30年を知れば5000人になります
飛田てもいいんですけれども1人ずつ送っていくのは先生を送っていうことをなぜもっ
てやらないのか
先生を送れば
その先生はホームステイしたところのにまた子どもたちを連れてくるとか国際化にも
役立つ
だから私は大人がもう少しやらなきゃいけないそれはスカラシップをやること先生教育
をやることさっき言ったように会社の
就活のとき受験の帰国子女枠を作ることいろんなことでもっとやれることはいっぱい
あるんでそこをしっかりやりながらそれがうまくいかなくそれにも応じなければ愚痴を
こぼしてい
早く家起こしすぎじゃないだろう
なんとなく今大学の教師になりますと少しから性能味方になって
よく代謝の社長さんやなんかに会うたびもうちょっとなんとかできませんかねいうと
いろいろやってますがねえと言うけどダメに行ってないんじゃないかなという気がする
んで
繰り返し行っていきたいと
ちょうど1分後44秒になったので大体ここら辺でお話をさせていただきたいと思い
ますどうもありがとうございました